fears mounting about the spread of jihad
in America's prisons they say it's been
going on for years just this last week
at least two of those men busted in that
alleged Jihad Terror plot to Car Bomb
two synagogues in New York City but they
converted to Islam while they were
behind bars that Sparks worries about
moving detainees from GMO into America's
prison system could they convert others
and even recruit for Al-Qaeda Robert
Spencer is the director of jihad watch
keeps tabs on the militants who may want
to kill us in our country Robert welcome
I mean how bad is it what are they
teaching the inmates in our nation's
prison system about radical Islam it's
very bad and it's getting worse what we
see in America's prisons is uh a large
scale effort a concerted effort that's
Saudi funded and comes from
organizations like the Islamic Society
of North America which is an unindicted
co-conspirator in a Hamas Terror funding
case you know it's ridiculous that an
organization like that would be vetting
chaplain for prisons in the United
States but it has been and it has sent
these pris these chaplain into the
prisons where also the prison libraries
are full of jihadist literature why do
they just take this stuff and throw it
out why does the prison system allow
jihadist literature inside uh a prison
well you know that's an excellent
question and unfortunately the answer is
I don't think they know how to recognize
it I mean look you take for example it's
very common in prison systems to find
the writings of IB Tamia who was a
medeval Muslim scholar and people would
say you know it's just a religious book
it's 6 700 years old they don't realize
that Ian Tamia is one of the favorite
Islamic scholars of people like Osama
Bin Laden and other Jihad terrorists
today and he teaches hatred of Jews and
Christians the necessity to wage war
against Infidel States in order to bring
them under the rule and the submission
to Islamic law and so you know a book
like that is a subversive political
document but it's not recognized as such
by prison official well they would say
it may be religious in context but let's
do better than that Steve Emerson at the
investigative project has a tape that he
says is of a prison uh Iman who was
recorded as saying quote be prepared to
fight be prepared to die be prepared to
kill is that the type of language that
we want being taught in our prisons and
he's not the only one war Dean Umar a
few years back was actually suspended
from the New York prison system after he
was teaching that the September 11th
terrorist should be regarded as Islamic
Martyrs Warth Dean Umar was not alone
and he himself also was approved by The
Graduate School of Islamic social
sciences which was another Islamic
organization vetting chaplain for the
prison system it's been investigated for
terrorist ties it has very unsavory
connections well but you know the Iman
of the mosque where these men were from
the suspects in the latest Terror plot
he says it's really not a problem that
he teaches tolerance uh and that he
hasn't seen it uh at all really in the
prison system system uh do you think
that's a fair assessment I think he's
completely dishonest about that anybody
who's in the prison system whether
Muslim or non-muslim is going to see the
Islamic recruitment going on or they say
it's about 40 40,000 or so inmates a
year of being converted yes absolutely
and the the prison population of Muslims
is already approaching 6% which is much
larger than the population of Muslims in
the United States in general well that
doesn't mean though that they're radical
they they're militants or they're
not in
itself not in itself but there is a
concerted effort by these groups that
are linked to Jihad that are linked to
the idea that Islamic supremacism must
Prevail and the United States
Constitution must be replaced by Islamic
law they are the ones who are targeting
the inmates for conversion primarily and
it's the national Islamic prison
Foundation which is Saudi funded is uh
at the at the Forefront of this effort
and know that the Saudis of course are
the ones who are most virulently
connected with the spread of the most
radical they're not here they're not
they're not here to defend themselves at
that but Robert final m point your
website Jihad watch uh how do people log
in and what is it jihadwatch.org is uh a
news and commentary site giving
information about the Jihad as it is
being waged in violent and nonviolent
ways in the United States and around the
world updated Many Times Daily jih
watch.org all right jihadwatch.org
rappert Spencer thanks for joining us on
this Memorial Weekend Sunday here on the
Fox News Channel Jamie house speaker